Speaker 1: for some reason that I cannot fathom.
Tucker Carlson invited Candice Owens to analyze
and interpret the three guilty verdicts for
former police officer Derrick Shervin, who,
of course, killed George Floyd last year.
Yesterday, we covered live those three guilty
verdicts.
And what's funny about this is that Candice
Owens has no idea about anything.
It's not clear to me why she comments about
anything.
Never mind jury trials.
Owens has become sort of a conservative darling
in some circles as a, I guess, former liberal
who found conservatism and of course, being
a black woman, even though the right is against
identity politics, being a black woman gives
her a particularly useful identity to the
American right wing.
But watching her melt down and just grasp
at straws is both entertaining.
But it's also a reminder that tons of people
will see this.
They will see what Candace owns, what you
were about to see from Candace Owens.
And because they are unable to think for themselves,
they will accept it hook, line and sinker.
And that's a very dangerous reality.
Let's take a look at the first clip.
Speaker 2: Cornerstone's, you'd think in a
country like ours, very tough.
I mean, this is the most first world country
that's ever been.
You think the most civilized and the most
just here, you have to consider a murder case
through the lens of politics.
When you get to that point, haven't you already
given up civilization?
Speaker 5: Well, that's correct.
And what we're really seeing is mob justice.
And that's really what happened with this
entire trial.
This was not a trial about George Floyd or
Derek Chauvin.
This was a trial about whether the media was
powerful enough to create a simulation and
decide upon a narrative absent any facts.
Speaker 1: It's almost like she didn't watch
the trial where fact after fact, after medical
fact and documentary evidence were introduced.
Mob justice, what is she talking about?
And she gets even more divorced from reality
the longer she's allowed to keep speaking
and answering the same question,
Speaker 5: whether it was powerful enough
to repeat showing and talking about a nine
minute clip that came from somebody's cell
phone without adding any context, without
showing the full, you know, the full police
video, which they could have released.
They refused to release the full body cam,
which would have added more clarity.
Speaker 1: Now, this is sort of slippery.
She throws in that the video of George Floyd
being killed is from a cell phone.
So what what difference does it make?
That is from a cell phone rather than CCTV
footage rather than for K or whatever?
And then she Gish gallops right into the body.
Cam footage wasn't even revealed.
The absence of body cam footage doesn't change
this from a guilty verdict into a not guilty
verdict.
It's possible that if the body cam footage
was released, it might have shown something
different or it might have shown the same
thing, probably the same thing based on the
sort of clear cut nature of the video we do
have.
But the absence of a video doesn't actually
make the verdict wrong and it doesn't make
it mob justice.
And more importantly, with how frequently
body cam footage is, quote, lost or unavailable
due to technical problems, if there were no
cell phone video, for all we know, there would
be no video at all and we'd have zero accountability.
It is rare that you actually have such an
incident where there are witnesses and video.
When you were talking about the death of someone,
understand that, you know, the vast majority
of homicides, there's just no video and cases
don't have the documentary evidence that that
we had here.
OK, let's watch one more clip
Speaker 5: to the fact that the media was
lying.
You know, the media came out.
Let's not forget this sucker.
The media came out and told us that this was
a man who was just getting his life together.
He was a good, you know, good member of society.
And he got mixed up because a racist white
police officer had it out for him and killed
him.
All of that fell apart.
Speaker 1: Those actually are not statements
that really have anything to do with the trial.
You had jury selection.
Derrick Chauvin's attorney had every opportunity
to strike jurors, potential jurors, if he
felt that they had prejudged the case, that
they already believed that Derrick Shervin
was guilty or whatever they were is a fair
jury selection process.
Floyd turning his life around or not is not
actually relevant to the case.
She is completely off the rails.
Let's actually watch a little bit more here.
Speaker 5: All the facts came out and all
of that fell apart.
We now know, of course, that he had enough
fentanyl in him.
It was three times the lethal dosage, three
times lethal doses in him when he died.
But nobody cares.
Speaker 1: Doctors testified very specifically
during the trial.
George Floyd did.
Not die of a fentanyl overdose.
This is trash.
It is nonsense, but people are already repeating
this stuff on Twitter and elsewhere.
One more clip,
Speaker 5: because the media was successful
and putting out a narrative and they kept
hitting that narrative.
And the reason why the Democrats are happy
is because they realize, of course, the media
supports them and now means the Democrats
can get whatever they want because they can
create a narrative and then they can treat
people like pawns and get them to basically
say, if we don't get what we want, we will
riot, we will loot, we will send these people
out like soldiers to destroy your neighborhoods.
And that is exactly what has happened.
That has been the determination of this trial.
The media and the Democrats now have enough
power to bully, to bully and to lie to and
to create propaganda and to successfully win.
And that is what happened.
And they are celebrating that win today.
This was not a fair trial.
One single person can say this was a fair
trial.
Speaker 1: She's just completely out of control.
And who is she to say if the trial was fair,
there was jury selection and both sides had
a chance to weigh in on jurors.
They accepted the slate of jurors, the judges
there.
They will get a chance to appeal if they want.
But she just decided that this is not a fair
trial.
It's actually a tragedy that Candice Owens
is interviewed as some kind of expert.
I guess on what I don't know.
Democrats are happy.
This is the sort of, Don, junior liberals
want people to die of covid to hurt Trump
thing.
No one's happy about this.
I don't take joy at people going to prison.
I'm against imprisoning people as a sort of
general principle.
It's horrifying that this trial even had to
take place.
I would rather Derek Shervin be a good police
officer and George Floyd be alive.
But George Floyd is not alive and accountability
is necessary.
But what I do enjoy is the right wing melting
down over this verdict.
And we're going to look at some more examples
momentarily.